[Musique]
notre enquête commence au Moyen Age
quand les états pontificaux ne font qu'un
puissante seigneurie de la péninsule italienne
[Musique]
les papes possèdent un formidable
armée et couronner les rois d'europe mais
interdire au public de lire
bible originale emprisonnant n'importe qui
essayez nous aussi la ville de florence en est une
puissante seigneurie
[Musique]
le forint est une monnaie très forte et
les savants florentins forment l'élite
de la culture européenne
[Musique]
un de ces savants dante alighieri
est curieux de savoir ce qu'il dit
dans la bible
[Musique]
à cette époque, il est dangereux d'aller à l'encontre
les dogmes de l'église mais donnant à maintenant
tout ce qui est interdit et fait
commencer à la société secrète de son
ami je conduis chevauchant un homme de lettres qui
il connaît une énormité de choses interdites
Dante découvre alors que depuis plus de temps
certains anciens initiés arabes ont fait
transmettre secrètement les notions de
une technologie ancienne très avancée
les données originales ont été gravées sur certains
des tablettes d'argile
mais ils ont ensuite été copiés et traduits au
papyrus bien que très peu soient capables
comprendre les notions évoquées ces
les écrits parlent d'autres habitants
planètes
de chars volants aux armes éblouissantes
[Musique]
des communications visuelles entre les personnes
loin
de manipulations génétiques avec un
singe dont le résultat est l'homme
dante stupéfait veut tout savoir sur
ces textes plonge alors dans
les lire et découvrir un monde
fantastique
[Musique]
les abonnés disent que 400 mille
ans, une flotte de chars volants avec
à bord des géants entrez dans le nôtre
le système solaire forme des bases sur mars
et sur la lune et arrive sur terre en utilisant
oui en Mésopotamie
ces géants appelés anunnaki disent
venir de la planète nibiru et sont
600 entre hommes et femmes
[Musique]
leur équipage est composé de nobles
par des militaires et des scientifiques de
construction technologique très avancée
leur assise territoriale en Mésopotamie ed
un site d'extraction minière dans le
sud de l'afrique
besoin de main d'oeuvre
les anunnaki préfèrent dupliquer le
laboratoire animal adapté pour
travailler dans les mines plutôt que
fabriquer des automates en métal
ils fertilisent ensuite le laboratoire avec le
leur semence un primate femelle est-ce
après divers tests il génère le premier homme
[Musique]
est un homme apte à tous les emplois mais
il est stérile de se dupliquer
sans l'aide du laboratoire
les médecins ont un qui le fait
fertile et ajouter la femelle
[Musique]
pendant 100 000 ans comme le
les hommes et les femmes se multiplient
les anunnaki les portent aux quatre
coins du monde formant les premiers
grandes agglomérations humaines du
préhistoire
mais pendant les 100 000 ans qui suivirent
le nord gèle
[Musique]
et quand l'ère glaciaire se termine un
une grande inondation engloutit le monde
les anunnaki survivent en volant
ciel sur leurs chars mais la plupart d'entre eux
des humains est noyé par
les eaux sont un désastre
seuls les hommes survivent
se réfugie dans les montagnes et sa famille
d'oncle sur parmi les noms bibliques protégés
à l'intérieur d'une arche
[Musique]
quand les eaux se retirent les anunnaki
ils retournent en Mésopotamie réparer les dégâts
de leurs structures et siri divisent le
la terre a émergé pour en fonder de nouvelles
nations apparaissent ainsi simultanément dans
mésopotamie en egypte dans la vallée
de l'Inde en Chine et en Amérique centrale
les premières grandes civilisations après le déluge
besoin de travailleurs pour construire
nouvelles villes capturées par les anunnaki
les hommes et les femmes qui ont survécu
les inonder et les apprivoiser
[Musique]
mais une fonction et une forme
des tribus de nomades sauvages
[Musique]
dans les villes les hommes vivent avec
anunnaki et les considérer comme des dieux
divinité mais s'ils s'approchent sans
protection de leurs armes redoutables
ils meurent électrocutés
[Musique]
les anunnaki ont trouvé la pierre à
manière des volcans et le modèle pas sur
mesurer construire des murs colossaux
antisismique où stocker leurs armes e
d'énormes machines à produire
énergie sonore en forme de pyramides
mettre du blanc visible du ciel
rendre compte de sa position
[Musique]
pour nourrir leurs nombreux ouvriers
construction anunnaki dans chaque nation
de terrains clôturés dédiés
à l'agriculture et à l'élevage dans
ces champs les médecins ont annoncé
les plantes modifient les animaux
animaux sauvages des environs en les adaptant aux
alimentation de leurs travailleurs
devenir sédentaire
l'un de ces champs clôturés est Eden
[Musique]
à l'occasion de la partition anunnaki
du monde le puissant marduk reçoit le
la mésopotamie et construit l'eden au nord
de sa propriété entre la mer noire et la
mer Caspienne
[Musique]
besoin de personnel pour eden
marduk a capturé et apprivoisé
mille hommes et femmes primitifs
ces prisonniers appelés à des amis
ils travaillent dur mais ils ont la nourriture
assuré et vous n'avez pas à vous inquiéter
prédateurs plus l'extraordinaire
la technologie anunnaki augmente les capacités
comprendre les amis et les faire
une espèce d'hommes plus évolués le seul
précaution à prendre et de se raser
crâne parce que les mâles anunnaki font
exciter à la vue des cheveux longs et
ils ne font pas de distinctions sexuelles entre les femmes
et les hommes
[Musique]
il y a cinq mille ans, les Anunnaki
ils abandonnent la terre cependant pour que
leur absence la vie des peuples d'en bas
leur domaine reste le plus
confortable que possible dicter les données
scientifique aux érudits de toutes les nations
[Musique]
ces notions sont également dictées dans
eden où les savants aux amis le
transcrire fidèlement sur certains
des tablettes d'argile
[Musique]
quand les anunnaki quittent le
les tendances savent faire beaucoup de choses mais pas
ils savent mieux se battre en se défendant
les hommes primitifs le prennent alors
assaillir l'eden pour lui voler son
les richesses et les tendances sont forcées
pour échapper à
une cinquantaine de leurs clans dont
les membres sont reconnaissables à la tête
rasé puis laisse leven et s'en va
vers le vestige qu'il ne connaît qu'en bas
La Mésopotamie les a remis en service
machines abandonnées par les anunnaki e
entre le tigre et l'euphrate
ils construisent une citadelle royale pour
chaque clan donne l'ensemble de ces petits
les règnes assumeront
les tendances sont appelées sumériennes et le
leurs premières villes sont centre ville quiche
politique
[Musique]
ce n'est pas non plus un centre religieux et une maison
de l'élève qui l
le puissant oncle de marzocca
[Musique]
quand dante finit de lire e
fasciné
également à cheval et très intrigué par
Sumériens parce qu'ils prétendent que la terre est
rond et tournant autour du soleil
ce peuple ancien maîtrise
astronomie physique chimie la
Médicament
ingénierie de la métallurgie
l'architecture la minéralogie la
zoologie et même parfumerie
les Sumériens sont aussi champions en
mathématiques en basant leurs calculs sur
numéro 60 inventer l'heure et la minute
utiliser des systèmes de numération
métrologie algébrique géométrique e
ils calculent l'espace avec une grande précision
gérer son économie
ils produisent de petits sceaux en pierre
en forme de cylindre qu'ils roulent
sur des pains d'argile pour que
puis prenez l'empreinte du dessin
dépasser la transmission orale
inventant l'écriture qu'ils affectent
de tablettes d'argile
et c'est ainsi que les Sumériens racontent les leurs
histoires de vie leurs entreprises et eux
mythes précisant bien que les détenteurs du
savoir scientifique
ce ne sont pas eux mais les Anunnaki
[Musique]
les villes sur simple sont riches et cela
attire le hd un peuple sémitique de
Nord
les Sumériens ont besoin de travailleurs et
ils accueillent avec plaisir ces premiers téléviseurs
détesté et barbu mais quand le
arrive leur roi devient majoritaire
le jargon submerge les villes sur le fond et la forme
le premier empire de l'histoire
[Musique]
le siècle après que les Sumériens reprennent
puissant
leur roi architecte une idée directrice
Renaissance sumérienne et je dirais des sauces et des cris
faire d'ur la nouvelle capitale et de
de suite
[Musique]
la civilisation sumérienne dure deux mille ans mais
l'immigration massive d'un autre
les gens sont mythiques le rayon amor cause le
son déclin définitif
[Musique]
puis babylone devient l'héritier de sumer
et similaires certaines de ses technologies
mais les guerres de pillage détruisent
ces lieux historiques de la Mésopotamie
enterrant les tablettes sumériennes les leurs
savoir dans le désert irakien
[Musique]
cavalcanti, cependant, soutient que
l'ancienne connaissance n'a pas été perdue
à la chute de Sumer ses savants
ils ont transcrit les données des tablettes
sur des rouleaux de papyrus et s'enfuit
en egypte à memphis où ils ont rejoint un
des sages égyptiens formant un
société secrète composée d'initiés
[Musique]
le secret est nécessaire car dans
la technologie anunnaki de mauvaises mains ne fonctionne pas
il serait utilisé pour guérir le
maladies mais pour détruire les ennemis
[Musique]
tout comme les descendants de sa mère
Jacob qui a utilisé la technologie
pas à qui exterminer les peuples dans
cours de leur voyage vers le
palestine où ils ont fondé le royaume de
Israël
[Musique]
la bible hébraïque dit ceci
Je voyage en citant les anunnaki qu'il appelle
élohim et les mêmes événements que les
création de l'homme et le déluge mentionné
deux mille ans plus tôt dans les tablettes
sumérien
[Musique]
cavalcanti explique à dante que les anciens
Textes égyptiens grecs hébreux et latins
ce sont tous des remaniements
Inscriptions sumériennes
[Musique]
à l'époque de cette société secrète aussi
l'egypte n'échappe pas au conflit
dino viani et des persans l'anéantissent
État égyptien obligeant les initiés à
déménager de memphis en grèce
[Musique]
à cheval et convaincu que depuis le
Des initiés égyptiens sont arrivés à
la grèce le savoir grec a accompli un
saut formidable
Pythagore le premier Grec à être
initié à la société secrète égyptienne
perçoit dans les écrits sur les simples
système de calcul des angles et ne
en déduit ce théorème de géométrie qu'il
l'a rendu célèbre
Aristote est un initié qui étudie la
matière et c'est lui qui initie le jeune homme
Euclide devint plus tard un maître de
mathématiques et géométrie aussi
Archimède en est un initié
société secrète interprétant certains
notions sur de simples concepts physiques
mécanique et hydrostatique
plus tard la grèce et l'égypte sont
annexé au prospère empire romain
Retour de la société secrète byzantine
puis en egypte au centre d'alexandrie
de connaissances philosophiques et mathématiques
de l'époque et contribue
à l'accélération des sciences
mathématiques appliquées et arabes
[Musique]
quand les musulmans occupent l'espagne
Les initiés arabes passent le secret et le
leurs disciples espagnols et de là les
le secret des Sumériens arrive à Florence
[Musique]
donner et fasciné cette histoire de
les êtres de l'espace extra-atmosphérique et les leurs
la technologie l'inspire dans sa divine
la comédie
mentionne quelques notions techniques que personne
à son époque, il ne pouvait même pas imaginer
[Musique]
décrit l'apesanteur
dans le cockpit du char céleste qui
le transporte avec Béatrice au
planète de dieu ce char céleste taureau
à une vitesse infiniment plus grande
que celle de la lumière son chemin dans
notre système solaire à l'envers est
le même que celui de l'anina chi
décrit sur les tablettes sumériennes
[Musique]
le secret reste à florence où
l'amant de la Renaissance italienne
l'initié Marsile Ficin passe le
livraison à léonard de vinci
[Musique]
Leonardo est très intéressé par
notions mécaniques des Sumériens et comprend
alors que voler est vraiment possible
[Musique]
cependant leonardo n'a jamais réussi à
voler malgré son génie il n'en avait pas
que les jambes et les bras comme moteur
nous sommes en 1500 et à cette époque le
les mythes anciens refont surface avec la terre
d'arcadie où les bergers sont transmis
parmi eux une connaissance scientifique occulte
mais l'inquisition catholique accuse de
l'hérésie est tout ce qui touche à la nouveauté
scientifique
[Musique]
cela rend les initiés prudents et pour
deux siècles leurs notions demeurent
secret
jusqu'en 1849 un événement crucial
bouscule le monde scientifique des fouilles
archéologues mettent publiquement à la
lumière des milliers de tablettes sumériennes
enterré dans la bibliothèque du roi assyrien
absurbanipal
depuis, la technologie a fait le grand saut
le plus impressionnant de l'histoire et des moyens
jusqu'ici inconcevable comme
l'électricité la radio le téléphone le
le moteur et même l'avion arrivent
inventé soudainement et tout pour le
en même temps les armements passent de
mousquet au missile
l'une après les deux autres guerres mondiales
ils éclatent
les nazis construisent secrètement un
prototype de vaisseau spatial
en utilisant l'antigravité et éliminer
celui qui en parle
[Musique]
albert einstein avertit le monde
sur l'évolution nucléaire et nazie e
l'ingénieur spatial von braun déclare
que la technologie de pointe des Allemands
elle ne découle pas de leur intelligence mais de
un savoir ancien révélé
[Musique]
la russie ouvre l'ère spatiale en lançant
le premier satellite artificiel du
histoire spoutnik un gardant des secrets
ses inventeurs le vatican construit
en arizona le plus grand télescope du
monde pour scanner le cosmos à la recherche
de la vie extraterrestre
[Musique]
en peu de temps ils étaient là
marcher sur la manipulation de la lune
la génétique
les ordinateurs
[Musique]
l'Internet
interconnexion vidéo
comment l'humanité a-t-elle
accomplir tout cela en l'espace de
temps si limité
[Musique]
la réponse peut être dans le
découverte des tablettes sumériennes depuis
décrire toutes ces inventions
[Musique]
qui sait si le désir de l'anina chi
quand ils ont transmis aux hommes le
leurs notions scientifiques se réaliseront
pour de vrai
[Musique]
dans ce cas si la pollution n'est pas là
ça empoisonnera et si le nucléaire n'arrivera pas
sauter en l'air
il faut remercier chaleureusement les Sumériens
si on ne restait pas à l'âge du bronze
[Musique]